it's back-to-school season we hope  you're ready and excited we're feeling  excitement here at CBS this morning it's  a new year gets underway so we're  inviting you to share your excitement  with us on social media if you have a  story about a favorite teacher a fun  classroom memory or a word of  encouragement for students or a message  to your community school we want to hear  it we do want to hear it so record your  video horizontally keep it to 45 seconds  or less and uploaded to our website CBS  news.com slash back to school or you can  post it to facebook twitter or instagram  with the hashtag CBS back to school your  video may appear on CBS this morning in  the coming weeks